here now to respond is mark fuhrman
former LAPD homicide detective and a Fox
News contributor and John you former
Deputy Assistant Attorney General
mark this has always been a bit of a
trouble spot for the Democrats as a
party but why are they increasingly
turning their yeah I think their
frustration and upset toward all law
enforcement not just a few bad apples
but to all of law enforcement well Laura
when you when you look at it they're
trying to attract that base that 18 to
25 year old base that is involved in all
these movements these anti-government
anti-establishment anti Republic and
anti Trump they're trying to attract
that group of people and the police so
it's it's very easy to attack them
because they don't respond to a call or
any crime of violence and wonder if
somebody is a liberal or a conservative
a Democrat or a Republican they just
respond and they do what's appropriate
at that time for whoever so they can do
anything they want and they know the
police are gonna still do their jobs and
the problem is is when you pick out
cases that they know that the police
actually did nothing wrong and that the
person that actually died or was injured
actually contributed to his own
situation they never call that person on
his responsibility to conduct himself a
certain way so they they win all the way
around
yeah and John it's very fashionable to
push for the release of criminals it's
it's a fashionable thing to do and
there's merciful merciful I think aspect
to all of us but when you are a party
that is actively attacking pro-law
enforcement experiences of some of your
candidates I mean that's the negative
thing it's if you were tough on crime
you can't be in this party almost yeah
that's a wild place to be so they went
after Booker and Newark and this
was a bit on Kamala Harris's record
let's watch senator Harris says she's
proud of her record as a prosecutor and
that she'll be a prosecutor president
she put over 1500 people in jail for
marijuana violations and then laughed
about it when she was asked if she ever
smoked marijuana I am proud of making a
decision to not just give fancy speeches
or being a legislative body and give
speeches on the floor but actually doing
the work the people who suffered under
your reign as prosecutor oh you owe them
an apology so it's not the victims of
crime John who are suffering it's the
people who are put behind bars what I
wish people like Harris or Booker or any
of the people been in responsible
positions would do would be to defend
the police and the prosecutors and also
the record of success that's been
happening this country for the last 25
years people forget you know this is the
Democratic Party says of the party
effects well the facts are in the last
25 years violent crime has dropped by
50% in this country property crimes have
dropped by 70% they should be proud of
that record as success and that's not
just elected politicians that's police
prosecutors judges people who make the
criminal justice system go instead in
the debates you hear someone like
Elizabeth Warren saying things like the
criminal justice system is racist from
front to back and blaming the police
when instead they should be proud that
they have dropped crime weights at such
a great that's such enormous levels for
a 25 year period there's nothing like it
in American history and we have a really
big problem in certain American cities
in surrounding areas
of recruitment of police mark Fuhrman I
mean we're in a difficult time getting
people to even take the civil service
exam to be considered to be a police
officer in some districts I that is that
really what they want to make it such an
unpopular career choice that young men
and women just decide you know it's not
worth it then where are we gonna be well
I think what they want is a police force
that is made up of people that really
don't have the pride for what they're
actually chosen as a profession and they
will go along to get along
and the problem is is we're talking
about listening to politicians that are
trying to be elected you can't trust a
thing they say I mean you could barely
trust any politician any time to believe
what they're going to say and here we
are trying to form our whole
law-enforcement attitude across the
nation because of 22 people that are
running for the Democratic nomination
it's actually absurd when you look at
this
they had ample opportunities many times
under Barack Obama and Eric Holder to
actually hold officers responsible
criminally in cases where there was
racial overtones of Ferguson a few other
places and the Justice Department did
not they found that there was no
violation we had grand juries that were
found that there was no violation but
that isn't that isn't the platform that
actually carries these people yeah but
the names those names were still thrown
around in the debate when I say Michael
Brown like that officer Wilson could
never work again as a police officer
his name was dragged to the mud after
Ferguson he had I think he had to change
his name
he can't even he can't he's not gonna
give an interview he's you know he was
accused of basically murdering someone
in cold blood and that's not what the
findings were so that was really
irresponsible there's some pictures from
Ferguson John I want to ask you about
what Harris said senator Harris said
about I think it was Castro actually was
Castro said at the debate about a
national use of force standards so
federalizing the police use of force
issue watch whether it's the case of
someone like Tamir rice or Michael Brown
or Eric garner where the Trump Justice
Department just decided not to pursue
charlie
we need to ensure we have a national use
of force standard and that we end
qualified immunity for police officers
so that we can hold them accountable for
using excessive John quickly on this
federalizing use of force standards
Laura I'm glad you played that clip
because that's unconstitutional it's not
the federal executive branch's job to go
around examining the use of force in
every state and city this is an area
where the Constitution itself places
limits the reasonableness test on police
at every level of jurisdiction city
state local it's not the job of the
federal government that you know
congressmen are you know secretary
Castro's proposals unconstitutional
second it's a sound byte looking for a
problem because if you look at the
statistics out in the most recent
studies there is no actual racial
difference in the use of force and
police shootings in the country yeah no
one no one believes even if you say that
and factually based you know the left
will not believe it and they'll keep
spreading lies all right mark I want to
get to this controversial decision
tonight in New York where NYPD has
suspended the police officer involved in
that chokehold death of Eric garner back
in July 2014 the video looked terrific
he said he couldn't breathe today a
judge recommended that officer Daniel
Pantaleo be fired from the department
Mayor Bill DeBlasio supports it until
today the garner family has been failed
by this entire process and as all this
stretched on it reinforced the suspicion
as one felt by millions that justice
doesn't exist for people who look like
Eric garner well the New York City
police union president Pat Lynch fired
back I stand here today to tell every
New York City police officer and they're
on patrol right now when someone calls
911 Don someone call your sergeant first
call emergency service second because
you will not have the backing of the
city mark pretty strong
whereas your thoughts well when you look
at the Eric garner case it wasn't a
horrific altercation it was a kind of
slow kind of resistance I'm not going to
go his size complicated everything he
did not apply a chokehold he had a
takedown hold that he immediately
removed his arm his physical condition
and the situation might have caused his
death we don't know and I don't think
there was anything conclusive so you
have the federal government the
Department of Justice under President
Obama and Eric Holder that has this case
for two years and they can't seem to
make a movement on it you have a grand
jury that clears the officer now you
have the Justice Department under
attorney general bar that says there's
not enough evidence for any kind of
civil rights violation a violation that
takes intent not just the conduct of
somebody that happens to create his own
altercation and now he renders himself
dead this is not a situation where there
should be a civil rights violation or an
indictment but unfortunately because of
public opinion that these Democrats want
they're going to actually probably fire
this officer well I don't know what
that's gonna do to the morale that's
already I think fairly low and and
throughout the boroughs of New York City
mark and John thank you so much for this
discussion tonight